whole truth and nothing but the truth in
sometimes harrowing testimony four
police officers detailed a coordinated
attack on the u.s capitol
and on them
washington police officer michael
fanon's own body camera captured him
being pulled into the crowd of donald
trump supporters
beaten and shocked with a taser mike
stay in there buddy
bike it's jimmy i'm here
he says the response from republican
politicians has been
just as hurtful the indifference
shown to my colleagues is disgraceful
but nothing truly nothing has prepared
me to address those
elected members of our government who
continue to deny the events of that day
and in doing so betray their oath of
office
washington metropolitan police officer
daniel hodges
seen in a viral video being crushed
between the capitol doors by rioters
urged congress to act i need you guys to
address
if anyone in power had a role in this
we're not allowed to u.s capitol police
officer harry dunn recalled being
taunted with racial slurs
no one had ever ever
called me while wearing the uniform of a
capitol police officer
just two republicans joined the panel
defying their party to question the
officers
you guys may like individually feel a
little broken
but you guys won
you guys help you hear uh former
president trump
say quote it was a loving crowd
there was a lot of love in the crowd how
does that make you feel
it's upsetting it's a pathetic
excuse for his behavior for something
that
he himself helped to create this
monstrosity
i'm still recovering from those hugs and
kisses
that day
the house select committee saw
previously unseen video
some of it graphic profane and
threatening
five people died on capitol hill on
january 6th
but despite the presence of two
republicans on the committee the
republican party
is largely refusing to cooperate with
the inquiry
in solidarity with donald trump who
urged supporters to march on the capitol
house republican leader kevin mccarthy
says the hearing is nothing but
political theater
that becomes a failed committee and a
failed report a sham that no one can
believe
as the hearings continue the effort to
investigate the insurrection
continues to be matched by an equally
aggressive campaign
to discredit it john hendren al jazeera
washington